for free to play stuff and I do think
that's going to change maybe it maybe
the last of us will be free to I don't I
really don't know but my assumption is
that they're trying to sell it to you
first I think they would try to sell it
to you or at the very least it would be
like hey um do you have uh PS plus yeah
like maybe they'll do something like
that maybe maybe maybe
it comes day and date to PS plus
maybe that's maybe that's why
because it's a way for them it's a way
for them still to charge you it's right
we compete with Game Pass and it's yeah
you know what they're probably trying to
do Chris they'll probably whatever
they're going to do in terms of Ip with
Last of Us let's say they they re-re-re
remake The Last of Us Part Two and and
then they're like if you buy The Last of
Us Part Two remake you get you get the
money yeah Last of Us Part Two remake
part one uh comes with the multiplayer
Perfections and then Last of Us Part Two
rebate part two uh remake remastered
they split up the game into two games